first you get it it's my response to
biden's congressional address
now to hear biden tell it america is
just
completely plagued by emergencies
no one nation can deal with all the
crises of our time
pandemics the climate crisis systemic
racism in our criminal justice system
gun violence has become an epidemic in
america the
insurrection was an existential crisis a
test
of whether our democracy could survive
but the struggle is far from over
of course biden left out the only real
crisis that our country faces right now
the one at our border a crisis of course
he created
he fueled and now he's just totally
ignoring
but have no fear because biden's not
going to let all of those pretend crises
go to waste
after just 100 days i can report to the
nation
america is on the move again
parallel into possibility crisis
to opportunity and the strength
can't stop now we're at a great
inflection point
in history we have to do more than just
build back better
to build back we have to build back
better
in other words biden sees all of our
emergencies as opportunities to remake
the country
into something none of us recognize and
it won't be the america that you know
and love
and the policies that made this country
strong and wealthy
fines is going to kill them all 650
people
increased their wealth by more than one
trillion dollars during this pandemic
and they're now worth more than four
trillion dollars
my fellow americans trickle down
trickle down economics has never worked
okay if that's the case mr president why
are americans so much
wealthier than pretty much every other
country
if this big government approach to
economics actually worked
the europe and canadian model would be
much wealthier than our model
but as you can see from this chart
they're not
but come on of course facts don't matter
they never mattered to biden or the left
which is why
they're just gonna come for your wallets
it's time for corporate america
and the wealthiest one percent of
americans have just begun to pay their
fair share
just their fair share
i think you should be able to become a
billionaire and a millionaire but pay
your fair share it's insanity to ask
hard-working americans no matter how
much money they make to give more
to a bunch of bureaucrats in washington
if anything we should be looking to cut
government and get americans
more of the money that they make and
stay in their own pockets
now biden's point is that our economic
system is fatally flawed
and needs to be replaced by again a
european model
that has historically performed much
worse than our own
but here's the thing we already we
already already know
our policies worked that have already
been tried
like low taxes limited regulation border
enforcement
tight labor markets and an america first
trade and foreign policy
now we all know we had this system in
place from 2017
until 2020 and it worked like a charm
so the only reason we have any economic
problems today
is because democrats insisted on
lockdown measures
which they're now taking their sweet
time to unwind
in fact americans are doing very well in
those parts of the country where
they have their traditional freedoms
back
the idea that we would imitate europe or
go back to the days of jimmy carter is
simply inane it's nuts
that's why conservatives need to reject
biden's claim that our country is in
crisis at all
these only exist in the minds of leftist
ideologues who hate america anyway
when our economy grows the left just
pushes for higher taxes
when our industry is booming the left
claims it's a climate crisis
when law and order is being enforced the
left just sees systemic racism
they're only happy when americans are
downtrodden and miserable and
apologizing
the gop should ignore all this talk of
crisis
and just point to the obvious fact that
places that
implement our policies are doing fine
we're going to talk to some of those
governors tomorrow
at every opportunity republicans should
talk up the success stories in their own
communities
and they should emphasize that our we
are not going to emulate people who hate
this country
and whose policies can never work now
remember this
biden is assuming that all those
suburbanites and all those moderates who
voted for him
that they want higher taxes and bigger
government
well in 2022 we're going to find out if
he's right